thay mặt cho đàn nhận lước như dập Việt Nam, chúng tôi không xin chúc bận và rất là buổi.
Nói trước khi những cái thành tiểu rất là quan trọng,
mà nhân dân nha đã đặt được.
Mà cái nạn ở vừa quà rất nhiều, có khó khăn khách thức và giới sự lấy đạo của đúng chỉ.
Thế và chúng tôi cũng rất là mong và cú tín.
Là lì bằng nạn giới sự lấy đạo của đúng chỉ sẽ chào thành một cái lực nạn vi đại.
Nếu lần xa mặt thành một cái chúc có đêm là chúng ta giữa rư dình và cái bảo vệ cái hạ bình,
cái công li và cái vôn đầy phát triển của vừa vật phát triển thế giới.
Vừa nạn xe đến đây, xe bý siet được cho chua.
Vậy là một người đường bây tỏ vui mừng lần đầu tiên được các tổng thống ngà trên công việc chú tích nước.
Họng định đà.
Nhà nước vẫn nhân dân Việt Nam rất trên trong và biết ở lì số chương đầy và lý băng ngàn ngày nay đã dành cho Việt Nam sự uống hộ.
Su đỡ vào lớn trong cuộc đổ chân sẽ phóng dân tộc.
Thống nhất đất nước cũng như trong sự nghiệp xe dựng và bảo vệ tụi quốc.
Chú tích nước chuyển lời cảm ơn của lãnh đạo nạn.
Nhà nước vẫn nhân dân Việt Nam tới tổng thống bu tín và nhân dân nha về những lời chúc mừng tốt đẹp.
Và việc cửa đổi dễ dự quốc quân đổi nha tham dự lễ dự bình kiểm tà miếng năm cuo khánh ngày 12 tháng 9 của Việt Nam vừa qua.
Nhà dịp này, chú tích nước sẽ dẻ các mục tiêu phát triển chế lực mà đảng và nhé nước Việt Nam để ra cho các mức 1 năm tình lập đảng và 1 năm lập nước.
Chú tích nước hàng định Việt Nam rất khó chọng quan hệ vui ngà, luôn quan tâm ủng hộ nước ngà phát triển uống định.
Bố mạnh, phát triển và trò tích cửa xe dự ự quốc quân phát triển thế giới, sát sáng tục đẩy hợp tắc dưới nào và a sàng.
Chú tích nước tình tự rằng dưới sự lễ nạo của tổng thống bu tín, nhân dân nha sẽ tốt đặt được những thịnh tự tổ lời nòn.
Để tốt đẩy hơi nữ khoảng hệ hai nước, chú tích nước lương cửa hàng định Việt Nam quan hệ các dân nghiệp nà tình các hữu đi mới trong lễ quốc đồ tư và các ngủ công nghiệp.
Hợp tắc sẽ sốt xúc phẩm, công nghệ thông tin, công nghệ số, tại Việt Nam.
Tổng thống bu tín về tỏ vui mừng gặp chú tích nước lương cửa trong bối cảnh hai nước đặc kiện nghiệp 15 năm tích lập quan hệ má dọng.
Hàng định hà rất kơi trong quan hệ hữu nghị chuyển thống, hợp tắc nhiều mặt với Việt Nam.
Ông chuyển lời chúc mừng tối đảm, nhé nước và nhân dân Việt Nam sẽ tảm viên năm 2020, hình đất nước.
Hàng định chia sẻ nhân vui về những tình dự quan trọng của Việt Nam sau tảm viên năm 2020 và phát triển đất nước.
Tổng thống là tín tự Việt Nam sẽ tự tình tự dựng những thống lợp tự tối lời n hơn, đong có tích cực vào hòa bình, hợp tắc và phát triển đổ hú vực và triển thế giới.
Hàng định đạo nhất chỉ cùng của quan hệ hệ hữu nghị, ngoại sao tốt đẹp.
Chỉ khai hiệu quả các thoả tận đã đặt lựu trong chuyển thông cấp nhé nước đến Việt Nam của tổng thống bu tín thằng sau năm 2020 và chuyển thăm chính thức ngà của tổng biệt thư tư tôn thằng năm 2020.
Tăng cường tiếp xúc, chào đổi đoàn, nhất lại đần cấp cao.
2 bên nhìn mạnh cứ tâm lưng tâm hợp tắc chính tế, thương mặt đổ tư cho tự dự dự vời quan hệ chính chỉ tốt đẹp và tinh năm của mỗi lúc.
Tích cực chứng khai, tức hiện kế hệ tổn thị về tóc Việt Nam, ngà đến năm 2020, một cờ hơn nữa thì chừng cho các mặt hàng sức hậu của nhau.
Để mạnh hợp tắc sau khi, nặn lượng hỗ trở các linh dành về sau phía châu và vũs phía phía châu, đề nhất đầm phán các phía định về hợp tắc trong lĩnh thuộc định hạt nhân.
Đông thời, hai bên cũng như chỉ tăng cường hợp tắc trong các lĩnh thuộc của phòng, anh em phở tắc quân dự như kêu khóa bình, anh em mạng, kìm sát internet về tình, tuổi hợp tắc trong lĩnh thuộc ít tế, giáo dục, đào tạo, giáo lưu nhìn dân, giáo dùng bở tài.
Du liệt, đông thời tiếp tục tăng cường vối hợp, ủng hộ lẫn nhau tại các sinh đàn cúc tế và khu tục quan trọng nhất là lĩnh thuộc của phá xe anh.